Transcriptor: Alec Collado
Revisor: Emma Gon
(Música)
Uno de nuestros mayores atractivos
aquí, en España,
son nuestras hermosas costas.
Concretamente en la Comunidad Valenciana
contamos con 470 km de ellas.
Todas colmadas de belleza,
naturaleza y biodiversidad.
Pero no las cuidamos
como se lo merecen.
¿Alguno de vosotros y de vosotras,
sabría decirme qué tienen en común,
absolutamente todas las costas
de la Comunidad Valenciana,
algo que de hecho, tienen en común
con todas las costas mundiales?
Micro plásticos.
Seguramente hayáis oído hablar
de las colosales agrupaciones de plástico
que se crean debido a las corrientes
marinas en mares y océanos.
Hoy en día, en el Pacífico tenemos
millones de toneladas de plástico
que se están acumulando
formando una mancha
que es de un tamaño superior a tres veces
la superficie total de España.
Y me imagino que también hayáis oído
hablar de la cantidad de plástico
que echamos en nuestros océanos
y en nuestros mares por día.
Cada minuto están entrando
a los mares y a los océanos
unas cantidades de plástico equivalentes
a 33 800 botellas de plástico.
Que si lo miramos en segundos
vendrían a ser unas 563.
563 botellas de plástico entrando
cada segundo al mar.
Y bueno, no sé a vosotros,
pero a mí estos datos me aturden.
Me parecen tan grandes, tan colosales
que parecen inalcanzables.
Esto parece un monstruo con el cual
nosotros no podemos hacer nada.
Y sobre todo suena lejano
y no debería ser así.
Ya que aquí, en Valencia,
tenemos una de las costas
más contaminadas por los micro plásticos.
Según la Fundación Aquae,
aquí en el Mar Mediterráneo,
podríamos encontrar hasta el 53 %
de todos los micro plásticos mundiales
en mares y océanos.
Por lo tanto, no, esto no es
un problema de océanos lejanos
o de números impersonales.
Esto es un problema que tenemos aquí,
en la puerta de nuestras casas.
Pero bueno, no todo es gris,
existen maravillosas soluciones
para limpiar los mares de macro plásticos,
los plásticos de mayor tamaño,
como es el caso de The Ocean CleanUp.
Que han inventado una estructura
en forma de U que se puede arrastrar
sobre la superficie de los mares
y se puede de esta manera recoger
los plásticos en superficie.
Estiman ser capaces de limpiar
hasta el 50 % de la mancha del Pacífico
de la cua he hablado antes,
en solamente 5 años.
Pero bueno, esta solución,
así que otras más,
están enfocadas únicamente
a macro plásticos y no a micro plásticos.
Y dejadme que os explique un poquito más
sobre estos famosos micro plásticos.
Son los plásticos de tamaño
de cinco milímetros o inferior,
o sea los de menor tamaño
y los hay de dos tipos:
Existen los micro plásticos primarios que
son los que producimos específicamente
para usarlos en productos como
podrían ser productos de cosmética
o podrían ser también
mucha de las ropas que utilizamos
y están después
los micro plásticos secundarios
que provienen de la degradación
de plásticos de mayor tamaño.
Y ambos están apestando
nuestro medio ambiente.
Tenemos, ahora mismo,
estamos hoy en día
comiéndonos ese plástico.
Según un estudio de
la Universidad de Newcastle
ingerimos semanalmente
una cantidad de plásticos equivalente
a 5 gramos que viene a ser
como si nos estuviesemos comiendo
una tarjeta de crédito
semanalmente.
¿Y cuáles son las repercusiones que
tiene este plástico en nuestra salud?
Pues todavía no se han podido cuantificar
pero lo que si que sabemos es
que los micro plásticos a su vez
se degradan en nano plásticos
que son unos plásticos
tan sumamente pequeños,
que pueden penetrar dentro
de órganos, dentro de tejidos,
pero bueno,
no me parece que haga falta
saber cuál es la repercusión que tiene
cuantificada por así decir para poder
ver la repercución que está teniendo
el plástico en nuestro ecosistema
y que ya hay razones
suficientes para actuar.
Y fue a raíz de todo esto,
que desde Yudith Daen
quisimos hacer algo.
Yudith Daen es un grupo
de aquí de la politécnica,
donde nos hemos juntados diferentes
pues apasionados del diseño
que quisiésemos utilizar ese diseño
para cambiar el futuro a mejor.
Fue durante una de nuestras reuniones
en diciembre 2018
que decidimos que queríamos crear algo
para limpiar los mares de micro plásticos
y fue a raíz de esto que se creó "Yuna".
Yuna es una boya flitradora
de micro plásticos,
se trata por lo tanto de una boya,
una boya ordinaria
a la cual hemos implementado
en su interior un sistema de filtrado
que puede retener y
almacenar los micro plásticos.
Por lo tanto Yuna podría estar
cumpliendo dos funciones,
la primera, la de ser boya,
la de señalizar
y la segunda la de poder limpiar
los mares de micro plásticos.
Si me concentro en esta segunda opción,
Yuna podría ser colocada entre 1m y 10m
de profundidad en mares y océanos,
en las costas que es donde se encuentran
primordialmente los micro plásticos
donde se van concentrando.
Y aquí bajo el agua su forma aerodinámica
ayudaría a posicionarla siempre
a favor de la corriente para que de esta
manera pueda estar siempre filtrando
el máximo de micro plásticos posibles.
Su forma y su tamaño son de unos 80 cm
que es el tamaño de las boyas ordinarias
y podemos ver que está
compuesta de dos partes
esto tiene dos razones de ser:
por una parte la de poder abrir
esta estructura exterior
para quitar de adentro lo que es el filtro
y por otra parte abaratar costes
porque solo necesitamos un molde
para hacer estas dos partes.
Si me concentro en el filtro que se
encuentra en el interior de esta boya
está formado en diferentes etapas
cada una enfocada a filtrar los
micro plásticos según su tamaño.
Una vez que se ha llenado
podemos extraerlo,
extraer a su vez los micro plásticos
y darles un segundo uso.
Y como he dicho antes, Yuna también
la podemos utilizar como una boya.
Se puede colocar en superficie
pintarla de color amarillo
que es el color estipulado
por las normas marítimas
y de esta manera también estaríamos
erradicando micro plásticos,
porque muchas de las boyas que se
encuentran hoy en día en nuestras costas
están hechas de plásticos
que no son biodegradables
y que por lo tanto con el tiempo se van
degradando en formas de micro plásticos.
Todo esto, la idea conceptual la
fuimos desarrollando durante 6 meses
dentro del equipo para un concurso
que se llama James Tyson Awards,
que es un concurso que premia ideas
innovadoras y el diseño de productos.
Además estuvimos haciendo
una labor de sensibilización,
estuvimos difundiendo ese proyecto
para poder visibilizar este proyecto
este problema de los plásticos
en nuestro ecosistema.
Pasados estos 6 meses en julio del 2019,
alguno de nosotros decidimos
que queríamos seguir trabajando con
este proyecto para hacerlo realidad.
Y desde entonces hemos estado haciendo
muchos testeos, mejorando la calidad
y el sistema de filtrado interno y
nos queda bastante trabajo por delante
pero hemos conseguido grandes logros.
Hoy en día nuestra boya es capaz...
ya ha sido testeada el sistema interior
en sus condiciones de uso, en el mar
y hemos podido ver como puede filtrar
hasta el 96 % de todos los micro plásticos
entre 5 mm y 1 mm del flujo
que pasa a través de ella.
Además hemos podido
rediseñar la forma exterior
para que el filtro interior
tenga más capacidad.
Y bueno, sabemos desde
un primer momento que...
con una boya así no vamos a poder
erradicar todos los micro plásticos
y por eso también hemos estado planteando
el uso de este filtro en otras situaciones
porque al fin y al cabo el valor de Yuna
no está en su forma exterior,
en que sea o no una boya:
está en un filtro que es capaz de
limpiar y almacenar micro plásticos.
Por qué no utilizar este filtro
también en la salida de ríos
para poder parar los micro plásticos
antes de que entren en los mares
o el las entradas de salinadoras.
Y bueno como he dicho antes
con esto no vamos a limpiar
todos los plásticos del mar,
pero si que estamos
consiguiendo concienciar
y si que estamos mejorando
la eficacia de este filtro.
Al fin y al cabo son pequeños actos como
el de cambiar una boya ordinaria
por una boya que puede filtrar
los micro plásticos,
los que llevan a cabo
este cambio para a mejor
para limpiar el medio ambiente
de plástico.
Debemos empezar a sustituir
los plásticos que estamos utilizando
por otras alternativas más sostenibles.
Debemos también empezar
a instar y a replantear
a la industría del plástico
para que se deba tomar en cuenta
todo el ciclo de los productos plásticos
en vez de pasarle el coste
a la naturaleza y a la sociedad.
Es hora que empecemos
a visibilizar este problema,
y a posicionarnos en su contra.
Es hora de que empecemos
a cambiar nuestros modelos de uso
y nuestros modelos de consumo.
Y es hora sobre todo de limpiar nuestros
mares y océanos de plásticos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)